which shape matches all three clues so
here we have three clues and we want to
see which shape down below matches all
three of these statements so let's start
with the first clue
the first clue says the shape is a
quadrilateral quad meaning four-sided so
looking down here at our shapes let's
see which ones match that first clue
shape one has one two three four sides
so it is a quadrilateral shape two has
one two three four sides so also a
quadrilateral shape three has one two
three four five six sides so it is not a
quadrilateral it's a six-sided shape or
a hexagon so we can rule that one out it
doesn't match clue one so there's no way
it can match all three clues and finally
shape four has one two three four sides
again so it is also a quadrilateral
so after clue 1 we still have three
possible answers this first shape the
second shape and the fourth shape all
match clue 1 they are all quadrilaterals
looking at clue 2 says our shape has no
right angles right angles are also
90-degree angles right angles are 90
degree angles and they look something
like this and we often see them marked
with a square in the middle because they
are sort of like square angles we can
create a square from the opening that
they form that these angles form so this
is a right angle looking now down at our
shapes we can see right away on shape
one has two right angles there is a
square corner in another square corner
so this has right angles but the shape
we're looking for has no right angles so
we can rule this shape out shape 2 does
not have any right angles these are not
squared
corners and same will shape for no right
angles so both of those still match both
clues 1 & 2 so we have 2 shapes left
they're both quadrilaterals and they
have no right angles and finally our
last clue the shape has 4 sides we knew
that because it was a quadrilateral and
those sides are of equal length that
means each of the sides is the same
length looking at this first one that we
have left shape to it looks like these
sides on the ends are shorter then the
sides going up and down so it looks like
they are not equal lengths so we can
rule this one out but let's be sure this
last one works here these sides the
sides all look like they're the same
length but the way we can know for sure
that they are is these tick marks
anytime you have these marks it's saying
that any side that has the same amount
of marks is the same length all four of
these sides have exactly one tick mark
so they are all equal in length so shape
4 matches all three clues it is a
quadrilateral there are no right angles
and it has four sides of equal length so
shape 4 is our answer